[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Assassin's Creed origins does a good job
of teaching you the ins and outs but
there are a few things you might miss
here are our top seven tips to become
the best assassin you can be whenever
you enter a new area make sure to unlock
all of its fast travel viewpoints not
only does it make getting across long
distances easier it also grants you a
hundred-plus experience and an increase
to send news perception skills
throughout your journey you will
accumulate a ton of loot that actually
serves no functional purpose aside from
being sold to quickly offload this junk
simply go to the cell screen of a vendor
and hold down on the d-pad to
automatically sell everything
no sorting required
[Applause]
while it might seem tempting to sell
your legendary weapon once it becomes
obsolete don't in Assassin's Creed
origins you can visit a blacksmith in
order to upgrade your weapons
and since legendary weapons carry
valuable perks it's best to hold on to
these in case you need them later on
dawn and dusk is an incredibly useful
ability that allows you to quickly pass
the time of day it's handy when you want
to attack camps at night but you don't
have enough patience to wait in addition
some quests even require you to meet
certain characters at a particular time
of day so it's in your best interest to
unlock this ability as soon as you can
similar to earlier Assassin's Creed
games you are free to exit the animus at
any time to play as the modern-day
protagonist we won't show any footage in
order to avoid spoilers but to do so
enter the pause menu and simply hold up
on the d-pad there's not much to explore
the tomb where this character is set up
shop but there is a wealth of emails and
documents you can read up on the laptop
it's worth noting that you don't
actually need to approach the computer
to access event simply press pause and
read away this is a must for hardcore
fans of the series as there's plenty of
tidbits included in these documents that
allude to past games
both weapon bear and bow bear our
abilities that let you swap between two
weapons on the fly this may not seem
useful at first but the ability to cycle
between secondary weapons becomes
indispensable during unexpected
encounters in stealth and combat for
example if a stealthy attempt at killing
a guard with your hunter bow suddenly
goes south you can instantly switch to a
light boat to quickly murder the now
alarmed foe these abilities also
eliminate the need to have to keep going
to the menu to switch out weapons
are you too lazy to ride your mount to
your current quest objective no problem
AC origins lets you set your mount to
automatically follow a path to the next
destination simply hold the X button on
Playstation or the a button on Xbox and
kick back and relax as your mount does
all the work if there's anything we
missed help out your fellow assassins in
the comments below if you want to check
out our review of Assassin's Creed
origins head on over to GameSpot comm
thanks for watching
[Music]